[Music]
i'm emily garland and i'm a gingerbread
house builder
what i now do is almost entirely
gingerbread replicas of existing
buildings normally quite large scale but
it's all edible
[Music]
sorry
okay
i think i actually initially got into
gingerbread because i wanted to do
woodwork but i also liked baking and
it's the perfect crossover between the
two and as soon as i realized that you
didn't have to make just a standard
shaped house you could make anything
then i got completely hooked
some of the things i get to make are
epic and i love all of them
[Music]
we're here in my kitchen studio which is
in hackney in east london this year i've
got quite a few commissions like this
one which is a private residence that
i'm making for a family to have as their
christmas centerpiece i'm just
translating my 2d drawing into 3d
cardboard always takes loads of time but
then in the end it makes it much easier
when i'm baking to know that everything
will fit together perfectly for me
christmas starts the first of september
i've had some things take three months
and then other things i can do in a
couple of days depending on the size
all of november and december is
back to back every day
sometimes one day off a week but rarely
and i accidentally do it every year
because
it's the season
i'm just going to put these bits
together roughly so i can start working
out the angles of the roof pieces then
it means i can easily take it apart
again without damaging the cardboard
because i'm going to be needing them for
templates to cut around
i'm not
a trained architect so the way i always
work is to sort of rough it out in
cardboard and keep cutting it until it's
right
[Music]
this is the first step of making my
dough i'm gonna melt together all of the
sugars brown sugar treacle
and syrup
my spice mix
basically whenever i come across
gingerbread in the wild and i try it
it's not gingery enough i feel really
strongly that the one thing you want
from it is that you can taste the spices
i've adjusted the recipe over the years
it's probably maybe at least three times
the amount of spice that they had in the
original i just wanted it to taste more
spicy
my spice mix is a secret because i spent
ages changing over time and now i'm
really happy with it i do tell people my
recipe because i love people to build
their own things out of gingerbread that
makes me really happy but i think the
one thing i'll keep to myself is exactly
the ratio of spices that goes into it to
make it so that mine's always
exactly mine i
have a recipe that doesn't have any
raising agent in it so it's got no eggs
and no bicarb or anything that would
make it puff up in the oven that means
that when i roll it out really flat and
cut the shapes out i know they'll hold
their shape in the oven which is really
important and it's quite a strong
structurally but not too tough to eat it
i think it's quite a nice balance i've
spent a long time working on my dough
recipe
so my biggest tips for people who are
starting out trying to make a house at
home would be to make sure all of the
pieces are baked to the same amount if
you're trying to just build a
gingerbread house but one of the walls
you didn't realize was slightly on
debate the whole thing won't work
so i have a special rolling pin that i
use which has these rollers on so you
can change these to have different
thicknesses but i find them really
useful or you can use dowels to keep it
completely even as you're rolling it out
there are some tools that i use i think
of them more like carpentry tools now
i've got two very good quality knives
and then the zester that's my favorite
tool and i use these miniature silicon
spatulas that are pointed which i
sometimes use those as a sort of trowel
like a brick layer might use to build a
wall and you can pick up icing with it
but also the tip of it means that you
can really tidy up edges
so
some of the pieces are easier to cut
than others the smaller the pieces the
harder they are so now i've got the
pieces out it's time to put them in the
oven because i cut them directly onto
the sheet i just carefully slide it on
and then it's ready to go
the next step is to make the glue which
is also the icing which is
water
mixed with meringue powder which is
basically dried egg white and then while
that's whisking together i sift the
icing sugar ready to put in the egg
white in royal icing is the key
ingredient because it makes the icing
completely set really solid what i'm
gonna do once it's mixed is just dye
some of it with food coloring to sort of
match the color of the gingerbread have
brown icing for all of the joints so it
makes it very slightly less noticeable
and then i use white for decorating and
for around the outside and there's snow
if you want snow on the ground that kind
of thing so i just add the icing sugar
really gradually and then i'm going to
whisk it on high for about five minutes
this consistency works really well as
the blue
this is the shape we've ended up with to
fit in here just trying to make sure
everything lines up really well and then
my most used tool is my zester which i
use as though it's the kind of like
woodworkers use filings
and i use that on almost every single
joint because even though the biscuits
bake very well and they don't tend to
spread in the oven i neaten them up to
make them really square before i start
also to avoid having loads of icing
spill out afterwards
so this is some of the icing that i've
dyed brown i'm just gonna ice along all
the exposed edges
so i'm just going to add this little
side roof piece here just going to file
these down a bit
before i start
[Music]
some pieces are small enough that they
hold up on their own which is excellent
when i'm doing the big pieces at the
beginning i have to use a lot of jars
and stuff to help hold it up
the icing although it sets really solid
it takes a good couple of minutes before
it's got a good purchase on the pieces
it's all sort of a balance once it's in
place i tend to leave things about 24
hours before i'd say it's all completely
solid but after that time it is
surprisingly strong i think the icing
ends up stronger than the biscuit
i make edible pinatas so the whole
thing's made out of biscuit and then
full of sweets once it's all covered in
icing it becomes really surprisingly
difficult to smash
this i always find fascinating because
i think almost everyone else assumes i
must hate it when my work gets destroyed
or how could i bear it that i spend so
many hours making something only for it
to be demolished but i actively feel the
opposite it's my favorite bit of it is
to know
that someone's going to enjoy it and the
only way for them to properly enjoy it
is to eat it and the only way to do that
is to completely destroy it
it's just part of it and i think it's
almost more joyful to be making
something so temporary i love seeing
people smash them to bits it brings me
so much joy because i know that then
they're properly enjoying it
so it depends on what kind of building
i'm doing as to how much detail goes
into each element i am making as good a
replica of it as i can
but in the end it is biscuit
i want to retain the sort of essence of
the building and so it can be instantly
recognizable with this one i think we're
pretty close to the real thing
i'd say nowadays about half my work gets
eaten and half of it doesn't and it just
stays on display which i find quite odd
but i still think it's important to use
my same recipe because if i wasn't
making it actually delicious what's the
point i just make out wood or something
part of the enjoyment of it is the smell
and if you have a big display piece i
had one where it was as part of a large
exhibition hall and you could smell the
gingerbread from meters along before you
found it that was really lovely and i
think having that
smell of the real recipe is an important
part even if it's just for display i
like to use quite a range of things to
decorate my buildings and it always
depends on the client and what kind of
finished look they want sometimes people
want a very like realistic version of
the building in which case i would just
use quite simple colors or other types
of royalising to attach things like
baubles and little sprinkles and things
just to make it slightly more decorative
one of my favorite things to use though
is this edible metallic paint
you can get this luster dust and you mix
it with alcohol and the alpha evaporates
off and leaves just the dust behind it
so you can paint with it and get some
incredible finishes which i love using
because also i have just from a personal
point of view about eating biscuits i
often get disappointed if there's too
much icing on the biscuit when you're
eating it because you just want to be
able to taste the flavor and i want that
from my gingerbread as well so i like
using things where it's on the surface
but you can still see the texture of the
biscuit and the colour of it behind one
of the things i like to do is i use a
lot of small dots and edible sprinkles
and balls in my work to make the
equivalent of things like stone work and
extra detailing around windows and stuff
this is some of the bits where i
take a bit more artistic license at this
stage because once you've got the feel
of the whole building i start to try and
picture it more as a finished
gingerbread piece and think about the
most sort of decorative fun elements to
add obviously no house has big balls of
icing to the side of the door it'd be
nice if they did sometimes just these
bits can make all the difference from
the way it looks you can end up having
quite a plain facade to a really
christmasy building just from these few
decorations i always enjoy this bit a
lot
[Music]
it took me a long time to find my
particular style
when working with gingerbread if i have
made a london installation or something
i will have messaging people going i
know that this is you which is really
lovely and i think it's that i've
developed this sort of look that is
maybe slightly different from the norm
where i don't really overly decorate
with icing and i like to have those
clean lines and focus on the structure
of the building as much as the
decoration of it have you ever
considered going on a bake off
okay i'm not allowed
because if you've ever earned any money
from baking you're not allowed to apply
so i do always watch biscuit week on
bake off and i find it surprisingly
stressful i'm spending too much energy
willing them on to make sure they don't
collapse and like yeah it's quite energy
something
but i love to see it
the one thing i still have is the same
excitement and sort of childlike
enjoyment of playing with biscuits
that's what i want to encourage other
people to do it for because it's such a
childlike joy from playing with food
[Music]
to anyone who's thinking about making a
house this christmas i would say just
have loads of fun with it maybe try and
make something a little bit different
out of gingerbread and have a really
happy christmas